JASON SILVA: So I
feel like there's
a connection between the human
desire to lose ourselves,
and the human desire
to be enveloped
by a technologically-mediated
environment.
The reason why higher
fidelity, sense surround
sound, the ultimate Bose
speakers or Beats speakers,
we want to raise the caliber,
the intensity, the fidelity,
the resolution of the signal
that mediates us so that we
can lose ourselves in it.
There's something about
the dissolution of self,
technologically-mediated
ecstasy that we crave.
It's why we go see
enormous IMAX films.
It's why we used to go
to the Gothic cathedral.
It's why we're chasing these
technologically-mediated highs.
It's why the trope
high is associated
both with drug binges as
well as with high technology,
high resolution, high
fidelity, high, high, high.
Human beings want to
mediate their encounters
with the other, with
logos, with dream space.
And I think that our urge to
create better technologies
is a reflection of this
desire to transfigurate,
to have feverish hunts for
rebirth, to have catharsis,
to have illumination,
to become one
with everything, to dissolve
and to reconstitute.
That's just what
it means to be us.
That's the human story.
That's what we do, and that's
reflected in our shopping
habits in our hi-tech world.